chers amis chers amis bienvenue à vous
tous route qui est venu de toute la
france pour ce qui est un événement
majeur pour notre mouvement
le premier campus des jeunes
républicains depuis 2011
cette année ce campus prend des allures
de rentrer nationale pour notre parti
ce week-end est même devenue grâce à
vous le rendez vous national des jeunes
engagés dans la vie publique
merci à vous jeunes venus de toute la
france de montrer ainsi que la jeunesse
croit encore dans la république que la
jeunesse est au coeur de la république
on salue les jeunes et on les remercie
merci à vous tous c'est venu aussi
nombreux et d'être venus de toute la
france
bravo les jeunes bienvenue bienvenue
dans cette belle ville du touquet paris
plage en se jurant je suis fier d'être
le maire une ville résolument est
profondément tournée vers la jeunesse et
qui le prouve toute l'année le jour
comme la nuit
cela étant dit n'en abusez quand même
pas trop ce soir car on m'a dit qu'il y
avait encore des ateliers des ateliers
de travail demain matin bienvenue
également dans ce département du pas de
calais que nous aimons passionnément et
qu'à force de combat et de courage
nous parviendrons à sortir des griffes
d'un parti socialiste qui l'a plongé
dans la misère
comme il a abîmé la france depuis 2012
bienvenue également chers amis dans
cette belle région nord-pas-de-calais
picardie pour laquelle nous sommes hors
campagne aux côtés de xavier bertrand et
qu'il n'est pas question d'abandonner
aux mains de marine le pen
non non chers amis la région nord pas de
calais picardie ne sera pas de
laboratoire d'un front national
démagogique et impuissants face aux
difficultés que rencontre le pays
oui au tour de xavier bertrand avec
natacha bouchart avec bernard gérard
avec gérald darmanin avec marc philippe
daubresse avec sébastien huyghe avec
tous les parlementaires de la grande
région que je remercie d'être présent
nous allons nous mobiliser comme jamais
pour gagner et pour démontrer que oui
avec de la volonté des idées nouvelles
nous vous pouvons faire bouger les
lignes et remettent cette région nord
pas de calais picardie au travail avec
xavier bertrand
un grand merci également un grand merci
également très sincère aux jeunes du pas
de calais du nord et de picardie qui se
sont incroyablement impliqué dans
l'organisation de ce campus nationale
bravo et merci pour votre esprit
militant pour votre énergie pour votre
temps que vous n'avez pas compter et qui
aura permis un exploit organiser le
campus le moins cher et le plus sympa de
tous les campus nationaux c'est
d'ailleurs
permettez moi cet aparté c'est
d'ailleurs un exploit puisqu'ils
n'étaient pas prévus dans le cas du
budget qui avait voté au mois de
novembre 2014 pour 2015 n'était pas
prévu de campus nationale et bien grâce
à l'esprit militant des jeunes grâce à
leur volonté grâce à leur mobilisation
nous avons pu même cette année dans ce
cas d'un budget extrêmement raisonnable
organisé ce campus nationale c'est grâce
à vous les jeunes merci el jad
bravo les jeunes
bravo et merci je me dois citer leurs
noms
bravo et merci à antoine si la nyha
simon jean bart à valentin perrin à
thomas michon à faustine maillard et à
tous les jeunes du nord du pas de calais
et la région picardie
plus que jamais ce campus c'est le vôtre
vous l'avez voulu vous l'avez fait bravo
merci merci également bien évidemment à
notre président notre président nicolas
sarkozy doit nous faire l'honneur de sa
présence
merci merci merci cher nicolas de nous
avoir fait confiance et de nous avoir
permis de relever avec les jeunes
c'est incroyable défi merci également à
tous ce membre du bureau politique
secrétaires nationaux parlementaires
d'être venu malgré des agendas très
chargés
soutenir cette belle initiative des
jeunes de notre mouvement
merci alain juppé à françois barois qui
ont déjeuné avec nous ce midi merci à
notre vice présidente nathalie kosciusko
morizet qui est ici au premier rang
s'est dit nathalie merci et qui est une
fidèle des campus du touquet merci à luc
chatel
merci à christian estrosi merci à
michèle alliot-marie merci à alain
joyandet
merci à edouard courtial merci à roger
karoutchi
merci à frédéric lefebvre merci à
geoffroy didier merci à notre porte
parole lydia qui est ici merci hervé
mariton
merci à marie-anne montchamp merci à
damien meslot merci à georges fenech
merci à philippe goujon et merci aussi à
nos députés européens constance le grip
françoise grossetête et philippe juvin
merci à nos parlementaires d'être venu à
ce campus nationale au touquet cette
année cette grande réunion de rentrée au
tour des jeunes et d'une certaine façon
également l'aboutissement d'un long
travail de reconstruction qui a commencé
avec l'élection à la tête de l'ump de
nicolas sarkozy en novembre dernier
rappelez vous chers amis l'état dans
lequel était notre parti divisé
inaudible il avait peu à peu perdu sa
place de premier parti de france
une place que d'autres s'était empressé
d'essayer de lui prendre
comme beaucoup d'entre vous j'étais
intimement convaincu que le seul qui
pouvait redresser la situation était
l'ancien président de la république et
je vais vous faire une confidence
pas un seul jour pas une seule heure pas
une seule seconde depuis son élection
je n'ai regretté de l'avoir soutenu et
de l'avoir suivi comme je lé fais merci
bravo car le bilan est là le bilan est
là il est incroyable en à peine plus de
six mois cher nicolas nous avons un
nouveau nom des nouveaux statuts plus
moderne et démocratique
un nouveau bureau politique des
secrétaires nationaux au travail des
finances je saluerai aussi faillite
péchenard redresser et surtout les
républicains sont désormais écoutées et
ils sont revenus grâce à nicolas grâce à
vous tous c'est grâce aux jeunes au
centre de la vie politique française
merci du fond du coeur cher nicolas
au nom de tous les militants car grâce à
toi nous voilà redevenu la première
force d'opposition à françois hollande
mais aussi une force de proposition qui
va nous permettre de remporter les
prochaines élections régionales et de
préparer pour les gagner les prochaines
élections présidentielles et dans cette
remise en marche du mouvement
ce week end fera date en permettant de
franchir une nouvelle étape avec une
nouvelle équipe nationale des jeunes les
dernières élections d'ailleurs avait eu
lieu en 2010 bravo par conséquent et
bienvenue à marine brenier notre
nouvelle présidente jeunes républicains
bravo également à geoffrey cavallino
bravo bravo geoffrey bravo à toute
l'équipe nationale je crois qu'ils
peuvent se lever et je les félicite
bravo également à l'ordre du rô les
républicains ont besoin d'une équipe
nationale des jeunes forte source
d'énergie et d'idées nouvelles pour
notre famille nous comptons sur vous
comme vous pouvez compter sur nous
françoise de graphie ni un de nos
écrivains du xviiie siècle un peu oublié
disait que la jeunesse a quelquefois un
instinct plus sûr que l'expérience et
des moins jeunes qui sont ici
au delà de leur désir de vous exprimer
leur soutien sont tous comme moi
conscient que l'expérience la plus
aguerrie n'est rien si elle délaisse la
vie et les compétences de la jeunesse
qu'elle doit défendre et préparer la
reconquête de 2017 ne se fera que si
nous sommes capables de nous donner de
nous de nous nourrir chers jeunes de vos
idées de votre de votre motivation et de
vos talents et si les jeunes sont une
force militante nous avons absolument
besoin
ils doivent aussi prendre des
responsabilités dans mouvement et dans
la vie publique
la valeur n'attend pas le nombre des
années chernick au lac ne l'approuvait
d'ailleurs quand tu as été élu jeune
mère à neuilly
à 28 ans seulement sachent qu'ici dans
le pas de calais nous avons suivi son
exemple en donnant l'investiture aux
municipales départementales à de très
nombreux jeunes avec de beaux succès qui
ont prouvé que nous avons eu raison de
faire ses choix audacieux je suis très
simplement et c'est maintenant partie
des équipes nationales père henri dumont
qui a 26 ans a ravi par exemple la vie
de marck en calaisis
bravo pierre henry biarrot bravo
également à plat emmanuel gibson et
bravo à tous les jeunes qui est bien ont
remporté ces belles victoires et les
prochaines pour les prochaines élections
régionales je fais confiance et xavier
bertrand pour de nouveau faire une vraie
et belle place aux jeunes sur nos listes
des jeunes force militante des jeunes
candidats aujourd'hui élu demain mais
également des jeunes au centre cher
nicolas de votre projet pour la france
car il ya bien un domaine dans lequel
françois hollande a échoué c'est bien
celui là
rappelez-vous et surtout rappelons lui
cette déclaration du 22 janvier 2012
bourget si je reçois disait-il le mandat
du pays d'être le prochain président je
ne veux être jugé que sur un seul
objectif est ce que les jeunes vivront
mieux en 2010 est qu'en 2012 et il
précisait galvanisé je demande être
évalué sur ce seul engagement sur cette
seule vérité sur ces seules promesses
pas sur l'inversion de la courbe du
chômage qui finira bien par faire bouger
de façon artificielle à coups de
contrats aidés non il demande à être
jugé sur la jeunesse or sur ce point
son échec est totale et parce qu'ils
tous les jeunes parce qu'il les a
trompés parce qu'il leur a menti
notre jugement le jugement des français
doit être encore plus sévère
car la réalité est là et les cruels en
2015 un jeune français sur cinq vit sous
le seuil de pauvreté et 23 8 % des
jeunes de moins de 25 ans sont au
chômage et que font sinon les autres
jeunes
eh bien ils s'en vont ils quittent le
pays en 2013 27% 27 % des jeunes
diplômés arrivée sur le marché du
travail
voyez leur avenir hors de nos frontières
soit deux fois plus qu'en 2012
lorsqu'on interroge sur ce désastre
françois hollande répond que c'est la
faute de la crise économique que c'est
la faute des autres enfin bref c'est
jamais sa faute
nous nous disons qu'on ne peut imputer à
la seule crise économique cet échec
quand des milliers de jeunes quittent
l'école sans diplôme
et quand les enquêtes internationales
montrent que l'école française est
devenue une machine à produire
l'inégalité
oui notre mission première demain sera
de redonner espoir à notre jeunesse en
nous appuyant sur notre sur nos valeurs
de courage de travail et de mérite et en
brisant tous les conservatismes qui est
tous notre pays qui broie notre jeunesse
et dont les socialistes sont les
meilleurs gardiens françois hollande ne
comprend pas la jeunesse ils ne voient
pas en elle son formidable vivier de
compétences sa force vive son potentiel
pour nous les républicains la jeunesse
n'est pas un problème
elle est au contraire la solution une
réserve de force et d'idées une
formidable chance nous nous lui faisons
confiance et ce campus on est la
meilleure preuve
alors pour terminer chers jeunes
partagez vos idées
exprimez vos attentes aidez nous à
préparer la france de demain une france
jus
dans laquelle vous pourrez faire vos
preuves dans lesquels vos mérites seront
reconnus dans laquelle vous aurez toute
votre place
oui la france a besoin des jeunes tout
comme notre région a besoin de xavier
bertrand à sa tête et tous que notre
pays a besoin en 2017 d'un président de
la république capable de nous redonner
fierté espoir tout comme notre pays aura
besoin en 2017 à la présidence de la
république de nicolas sarkozy donc en
plus à tous
vive le touquet dit la nouvelle région
nord pas de calais picardie et vive la
france